when you see cocaine in movies it's
normally vitamin B powder or get to me
okay no no um or if you're not gonna
actually be ingesting it it might be
icing sugar well for Wall Street I got
bronchitis for three weeks it had to be
serious yeah what is fake cocaine it's
vitamin powder and we were just
literally doing fake Coke for like seven
months every day
I never had more vitamin D in my entire
life I think I could have lived in a car
over my [__] head I might be breaking
the law now
but I'll say it the character I played
chips cocaine
and I I always thought that that was a a
choice we made and and but yet not not
showing it but there is a seed in it but
which we never again never got into the
film
and I've always wanted to say sometimes
just so you know as some of the
behaviors coming from